[Música]
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson se disculpó por asistir a una
fiesta en su residencia oficial durante
el primer cierre de coronavirus del país
en mayo de 2020 la oposición exigió su
renuncia y lo acusó de mentiroso
tras diálogos con rusia el jefe de la
otan y jens stoltenberg afirmó tener
diferencias significativas con el
gobierno de moscú sobre ucrania las
partes se podrían seguir dialogando para
encontrar un camino de conciliación
política tenemos reportes desde bruselas
[Música]
y diez días después de los disturbios
que estallaron en kazajistán por los
precios del combustible activistas
denuncian la falta de información sobre
el estado de los detenidos que podrían
ser hasta 12.000 el gobierno abrió cerca
de 300 investigaciones penales por las
protestas
un cordial saludo mi nombre es ángela
gómez y estas son las noticias de france
24 en reinounido piden la renuncia del
primer ministro boris johnson después de
que reconociera que si participó en una
fiesta en downing street en mayo de 2020
cuando el país estaba en pleno
confinamiento el líder del partido
laborista quiere starmer le exigió
apartarse del cargo mientras el premier
se disculpaba ante el parlamento por
atender lo que consideró un evento de
trabajo
y
es tan ridículo que es en realidad
ofensivo para el público británico
finalmente se vio obligado a admitir lo
que todos sabían cuando todo el país
estaba cerrado estaba organizando
fiestas alcohólicas en town y suites
ahora va a ser lo correcto y renunciar a
nuestra gente
[Aplausos]
lo lamento lo lamento mucho lo lamento
mucho que no hayamos hecho las cosas de
manera diferente esa noche señor
presidente como dije asumo la
responsabilidad y pido disculpas señor
presidente revés para la defensa del
príncipe andrew luego de que un juez de
eeuu rechazara las peticiones de
desestimar la acusación que enfrenta por
abuso sexual de una menor en medio de la
trama del fallecido jefe víctima ahora
se espera que el equipo legal del
príncipe andrew haga otro intento para
que el caso sea desestimado con el
argumento de que la víctima virginia
giuffré no está domiciliada en eeuu y
ofrece afirma que fue traficada por el
multimillonario jeffrey epstein e para
tener relaciones sexuales con el duque
cuando ella tenía 17 años
el duque ha negado todas las acusaciones
y damos seguimiento de las
conversaciones entre los representantes
de la otan y de rusia que retomaron los
diálogos de tras más de dos años sin un
encuentro formal en la reunión abordaron
principalmente la atención militar en la
frontera entre rusia y ucrania donde el
jefe de la alianza transatlántica jens
stoltenberg llamó a rusia a relajar las
tensiones en la frontera con ucrania
nuestra corresponsal esther herrera
tiene los detalles
tras tres años sin sentarse formalmente
la otan y rusia han retomado las
conversaciones con las tensiones en la
frontera de ucrania como plato fuerte el
secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg ha admitido que la reunión
de hoy no ha sido fácil pero que se ha
conseguido un compromiso para volverse a
reunir y definir un calendario para
futuros encuentros y seguir abordando
todas las cuestiones que aún se tienen
que hablar el encuentro de hoy ha durado
una hora más de lo previsto aunque han
podido hablar de cuestiones espinosas
como por ejemplo la presencia de tropas
aliadas en el este de europa así como la
presencia de tropas rusas en la frontera
de ucrania y también las presiones de
moscú para que países como ucrania o
georgia nunca lleguen a formar parte de
la alianza atlántica algo que los
aliados rechazan porque recuerdan y
rusia no puede ser quien decida el
futuro de la alianza ni de los países y
por lo tanto tampoco tiene ni siquiera
derecho a veto para decir y este
encuentro se ha producido justo después
de que ayer moscú y washington se
reunieran en ginebra y paralelamente se
produce cuando los ministros de defensa
y los cancilleres de la unión europea se
reúnen a partir de hoy en francia para
poder abordar el papel de la unión
europea en estas conversaciones tanto
washington como la otan han asegurado a
la unión europea de que se la tendrá en
cuenta que no se tomará ninguna decisión
sin su consentimiento lo que teme
bruselas es que rusia quiera ningunear a
la unión europea rebajándole su papel en
el mundo y así también poderla dividir
kazajistán anunció la detención de mil
678 personas por su supuesta
participación en los altercados de las
protestas que iniciaron el 2 de enero
con los nuevos arrestos del total de
detenidos se acerca a 12.000 en almaty
principal ciudad del país distintas
personas exigen información sobre el
estado de familiares y amigos detenidos
se cumplen 10 días desde el estallido de
las protestas masivas en kazajistán y el
silencio va recuperando las calles de
almaty donde activistas familiares y
amigos denuncian el secretismo de estado
y la incomunicación con los detenidos
hay un centro de detención aquí
el departamento de interior es bastante
grande y aquí retienen a los detenidos y
abogados y mis familiares nadie puede
acceder los abogados deberían estar
presentes durante los interrogatorios
pero como ves nadie puede entrar en las
puertas bloquean el paso a los abogados
y los familiares ni siquiera tenemos la
lista de detenidos lo que sí se conoce
es la cifra de detenidos según las
autoridades se acerca a las doce mil
personas es tortuoso que hicimos una
protesta pacífica el 4 de enero mi amigo
incluso le pudo llamar hermanos santos
en equipo beach fue detenido este día 4
primero lo retuvieron en la oficina
distrital del interior y luego nos
dijeron que estaba aquí en el
departamento del interior pero estamos
aquí desde el 6 de enero y no sabemos si
está vivo o muerto y están jodidos
el gobierno kazajo ha abierto cerca de
300 investigaciones penales por
disturbios y agresiones a la fuerza
pública mientras que naciones unidas
pide que se investiguen las
circunstancias de la muerte de más de
160 manifestantes y que los detenidos
tengan acceso a un juicio justo
honduras bajo el derecho internacional
la gente tiene derecho a protestar
pacíficamente ya expresar sus opiniones
todos los detenidos por ejercer estos
derechos deben ser liberados
inmediatamente y al mismo tiempo tenemos
que dejar claro que también vimos
personas armadas tomando las calles en
almaty y en otras partes de kazajistán
taking the suites foundation of kansas
están con la protesta sofocada la
organización del tratado de seguridad
colectiva alianza militar liderada por
rusia anunció la retirada de las tropas
del territorio kazajo a partir de este
jueves
al menos ocho personas murieron y diez
resultaron heridas en un ataque suicida
con carro bomba en la capital de somalia
mogadiscio el atentado ocurrió cerca del
aeropuerto internacional aden adde al
parecer tenía como objetivo un convoy de
la onu que tiene oficinas en la
denominada zona verde que aloja también
embajadas y las fuerzas multinacionales
de la misión de la unión africana para
somalia
y ahora vamos con información deportiva
porque se cierra esta fecha de la copa
africana de naciones
desde dual a nuestro enviado especial de
federico cuevas verena nos envió el
siguiente reporte
estamos en dual es la ciudad más
habitada de camerún o en principal del
puerto del país bañado por las aguas del
golfo de guinea aquí se va a cerrar la
primera fecha de la fase de grupos de
esta copa africana de naciones con el
duelo entre guinea ecuatorial y costa de
marfil en el estadio de chapó ma línea
ecuatorial es el único país africano
hispanohablante es dirigida a su equipo
por el seleccionador juanmita y tiene 16
jugadores nacidos en españa
descendientes de 4 guineanos y que
cuentan con la doble nacionalidad va a
participar desde esta copa por tercera
vez en su historia aunque es la primera
que lo hace a través de méritos propios
en las dos anteriores participaciones
habían sido por ser el país anfitrión
enfrente esta costa de márfil que llega
frustrada por haberse quedado del afuera
del próximo mundial de qatar pero que
cuenta con una plantilla rica en nombres
como para aspirar a grandes cosas su
principal figura es el delantero
sebastián a leer del ajax goleador
vigente de la uefa champions league con
este encuentro de dos equipos de
diferentes niveles se va a estar
cerrando esta la primera fecha de la
fase de grupos en la copa africana de
naciones en otros temas el departamento
de trabajo de eeuu dijo que el mes
pasado la inflación del país alcanzó su
mayor pico en casi 40 años un aumento
del 7% de respecto al año anterior la
subida elevó los gastos domésticos
redujo las ganancias salariales y
aumentó la presión sobre el presidente
joe by denny la reserva federal
aumentaron los precios de los
automóviles la gasolina los alimentos y
los muebles en paralelo a una rápida
recuperación de la recesión por la
pandemia de modo que los estadounidenses
han aumentado el gasto en medio de la
escasez de trabajadores y de materias
primas
recuerde que en france 24 punto com
tenemos más información siga con
nosotros feliz tarde
[Música]